the san francisco 49ers had a
disappointing 2018 season because the
expectations were so high entering
thanks to a strong finish to 2017.
lots of injuries though and jimmy
garoppolo and jared mckinnon lost fairly
early mckinnon right before the start of
the season garoppolo week three against
the chiefs getting those guys back is
kind of like going out and adding a
couple of free agents right out of the
gates but when you look at everybody
else they've added aggressive bringing
in d ford you have a bookend in nick
bosa at pass rusher the the 49ers it
it's kind of like
an all-in move that isn't as obvious as
maybe it is with other teams because
they weren't a playoff team last year
but
you get the guys they had already on the
roster healthy and you add these new
guys to the mix
and this is a team that could stir
things up in the nfc west chris yeah it
can i mean when you when you evaluate
the san francisco 49ers i think the
first thing that jumps out to me more
than anything is the improvements the
defense made in the 2018 season the
defense was for real and really the
moments that struggled were moments when
the backup quarterbacks the guys filling
in for jimmy garoppolo really struggled
offensively and the defense had to be on
the field too much and they were out but
i look first off the roster and i go wow
okay defenses got talent their front
sevens got a chance to be special you
had d ford okay quan alexander middle
linebacker and nick bosa to your front
seven i say watch out for that uh
combination they have a chance to be
certainly a top ten defense maybe in a
top five defense and you hit on offense
mike you know uh offensive lines in
place they just need jimmy garoppolo to
stay healthy but now with mckinnon and
you sign a tevin coleman in free agency
out of atlanta who's got a rocket up his
butt he's a home run hitter kyle
shanahan used him really well when he
was the offensive coordinator for the
atlanta falcons and then you add the two
receivers they drafted in rounds two and
three debo samuel out of south carolina
and jaylen heard out of baylor mike the
offense is really complete and you know
last year i know you i don't know if you
remember i was telling everybody pump
the brakes on the expectations of the
49ers they're not there yet this year i
don't say pump the brakes i say they're
a playoff caliber football team or at
least in the conversation i would be
absolutely shocked if we got to
mid-december and the 49ers weren't in
the race for the sixth spot the five
spot whatever it may be in contention
somehow to to get in and play in january
first of all i got two things to say
yeah i'm still smiling about the phrase
rock it up is but because that is a
commonly used phrase in the football
industry one of the few commonly used
phrases that we can actually use here
right it's not a good thing to have a
rocket up your butt
it's not
it's that that requires urgent medical
attention but it gets used all the time
anyway secondly where does a team like
this fit in a division that has the rams
and the seahawks yeah that's that's the
big thing i mean we've talked the last
few weeks at how impressive this
division is all together you know is
this the year the rams maybe take a step
back a little bit you know the seahawks
we know they're going on the upward
trajectory you know the 49ers yeah
they're going to have to win some battle
tested divisional play i mean some
division games this year so i think
they're
every bit as talented as the seattle
seahawks uh i think kyle shanahan's got
great knowledge of that seattle seahawks
defensive system if you really look at
it since he's been in san francisco and
even when he was in atlanta they played
seattle twice there uh he's able to move
the ball on them on a consistent basis
the 49ers it's really just about staying
healthy and going out and doing it this
year the pieces are there the players
just got to do it this year
you know all that talk last week about
friction between kyle shanahan and john
lynch that's died down lynch addressed
it on friday in a radio appearance in
san francisco and he acknowledged what
we said it's not friction it's urgency
everybody understands they're entering
year three they have not lived up to the
expectations especially last year first
year there were no expectations everyone
was shell shocked from the the the chip
kelly uh experiment and the jim tomsula
disaster the year before that last year
the expectations weren't met this year
who knows but i i feel like they're
moving in the right direction and the
nfc west especially if the cardinals can
pick it up a little bit it's a really
good division chris it really is it's
tough and competitive i i mean i would
be shocked i really expect two teams to
come out of the nfc west and make it to
the playoffs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports